The graph would be this purple circle. We know this since the radius would be
4, which is the square root of 16. So out of all of the circles, we want the
smallest radius, that would be 4. Our center will be at 2, negative 1. We know
this since this sign is negative 2, so h is positive 2 and this sign is
positive 1, so k is negative 1. The large circles had a radius of 16 and that
would have been way too big. The next circles a size down had a radius of 8,
still too large. So, we were really choosing between the smallest 2 circles.
And it's this one because its center is at 2, negative 1. And if we zoom in, we
can easily see that. The center is at 2, negative 1 here. Now, I know you
didn't have this close up view for the circle, but the idea was to get an
estimate of which one you think it is. Based on the direction that the center
moved and based on the size of the radius. Sometimes it's just as good to have
a qualitative understanding of about what your graph should look like, rather
than an exact picture. That's what we were going for with this question.